on a ferris and Mariah Carey are rocking  blinding bling what do you think honey  Oh Chris Pratt put a new ring on it  upgrading his wife with another massive  sparkler for her special ring finger  Anna debuted the stunning opal cut stone  at the passengers premiere on Wednesday  in LA and the two lovebirds packed on  the PDA as they pose for folks on the  red carpet hashtag the diva  well this pop diva is also flaunting a  massive accessory Mimi was spotted still  wearing the 10 million dollar engagement  ring from ex-fiance James Packer for her  guest appearance on Thursday's Late  Night with Seth Meyers in New York City  although the pair called it quits in  October a source told ET Mariah's  keeping the ring and the singer is  asking for a 50 million dollar  settlement why do you think wronged  women deserve an inconvenience fee honey  we deserve so much more than that  amen we deserve everything  [Music]  you